so what is terraform and how can it be
used to help manage your infrastructure
what is infrastructure's code and how
can it benefit the business
in the getting started with terraform
for Google Cloud course you'll learn how
to use terraform and infrastructure's
code tool to create and manage your
Google Cloud infrastructure
the purpose of this course is to explore
the terraform workflow in detail you
will become familiar with the terraform
workflow and know the purpose of each
phase and how it's implemented
through a series of videos and Hands-On
Labs you'll explore the business need
for terraform and infrastructure's code
and the benefit to use them in your
environment
surmise the features and functionalities
of terraform
use resources variables and output
values to create Google Cloud
infrastructure resources use terraform
modules to build reusable configurations
and describe the terraform state and its
importance
are you ready to learn more click on the
three dots and click on the link in the
description box below to enroll on the
getting started with terraform for
Google Cloud course see you there